not like this not like this what's up
guys welcome back to the couch Dave
Jewett here with Lucy James tomorrow who
sane playing some undead nightmare today
since you a it's Halloween bleep really
Red Dead Redemption was just announced
yep Tempe for Halloween can you get
Western for I have yeah but it's been a
long long time
oh really that I got I remember I got
all the achievements in under nightmare
and I played a bunch of the horde mode
or the saying that I will probably suck
now is six years it sounds like you've
played the most so basically if you're
not a ringer and the best there you've
let it run down so let's get started
someone punch you
yeah no bunch of the pies you jumped oh
boy - rifle dobro shotgun hi-power
pistol I've got some holding
no it's undead Bay I was throwing I
wasn't throwing holy war at all oh my
god
all that time I was throwing undead bait
also by the way we have undead bait
hmm so if you were Oh God wow the Mauser
pistol is a if fires super fast
nice oh let's get the coffin you forget
about that Oh God
cover me chop and tuck oh I'm cheering
you sorry
don't shoot chopper tuck on your left on
your left hand nine o'clock there you go
before I go that's now my coffin
exploded in it caught my foot your weak
point your Achilles heel Achilles but
get some cream yeah this economy stable
god damn it
okay wait one play went I kidneys have
been sewn out kidneys yeah
stay off my back come here I'm gonna try
this undead bait combo is some dynamite
go come overi go there you go and throw
some dynamite at the undead bait I'll
work I'll do something boom oh Sh
they go new strats we can use the fences
for advantage in this map the Dave strap
oh wow this guy's just sort of them cam
go for the coffin
I guess shotgun slugs from a coffin as
well I believe
yeah let's go show my range I can open
the coffin for explodes run there they
come
it's came through the church there your
name through the church there is a
somebody shot me in the ass directly in
the ass it wasn't me what are you I
literally can't I'm too fat to get for
this game Bubba sub that jumped up and
bit Bay we got one so again a hill
somewhere to get his ass down here it
assume I'm gonna dead I said I know one
guy you guys racing so you can kill him
first he's stuck where is he oh there is
ice iam nice nice nice good kill em I'm
stuck on some rocks Lisa James more
enemy rock
oh wow there's love them okay I'm dead
bait don't all right throw the bait
throwing the accompanying dynamite whoa
whoa that's good squishy another
blunderbuss
Wow Oh help me move you good money good
I got you
boom ah keeps again they blow up I like
how so in the main game if you and I get
too close to one and you like fire them
it like just like a special killcam yeah
yeah and they say just they don't you
just know you slap them with your gun
pistol-whip take a pistol whip God one
more get your phosphorous here boom
double tap I remember my zombie there's
no one alive over there yeah that's
right yeah which is ready these waves
are into 100 there I'm going for coffin
I just want it shoulder check done oh
wow there's a bunch remember
fine um but like I'm the long range guy
and I still don't have the range she
doesn't have the range darling making
references it all gets God's arms are
the like now whacked me LF L Lisa's in
trouble I got you me actually a zombies
behind ya it's not like the cliche
moment in every zombie movie corny
accent issued friend nowhere you think
we got 30 seconds I read that wrong oh
yeah that's three minutes more that's
why I'm late to everything
yeah three minutes late it's a bunch
more down to the left
Wow there is no actually
fast for a little it's alright do you
mean you can't hold out much longer
don't tell me I can I can do don't tell
me don't you forget about me
don't dinner that's like this is a lot
of them but the looks are on the
mini-map there's like a horse
I know my eight yes cool though is a
floundering is doing like Phoebe in
frame okay well that's the pine gift of
them boom let's go let's go let's go
doesn't refill all our ammo yeah all
right otherwise your token thing to
steal the coughing from someone coughing
oh you cheated race what you talking to
me the race for a lifetime that's all I
do in life some people are missing
anything
oh damn alarm ugh and we got dead eyes
well know what you're dead I son
I mean as much as I love rockstar games
I cannot wait for the time that they get
rid of tap a to run yeah whoo
oh did anyone see that it's not as bad
as the fallout for developers like what
should we make jump I know why it was an
achievement loves to be weird with it
hey Bioshock is watching everyone weird
it's maybe like overwatch cute away in
the game except you have to do like
eight times because there's a million
zombies where are you guys
shooting that guy's putting a hot right
wave six we're doing much better this
time machine English is stay together a
bit more yeah sure why not let's go to
the coffee I'll grab the weapon no no
don't worry guys I'm right behind you
semi-auto shotgun I'm gonna get the Ajo
he knocked me to the ground I got you
how are you still alive after you -
shotgun shell to the face its resilient
Oh God
oh wow oh yes happening again check come
on you're gonna brain left I'm a
guardian angel apparently guardian angel
y'all don't forget it
Cowboys never die neither does mine well
Kevin Tucker
I like it
The Legend of manual cabin Tucker
churches this is God's house here get
your gas lower you shouldn't be seen
that in beat it the [ __ ] ever there we
go oh stop jumping I'm going to say
crisps listen I've been listened to a
lot John and Alice and I'm very excited
because I'm gonna go see them in a
couple weeks I'm gonna be setting keep
it session a lot is it like a back flip
it's not dead though Angelo say I'm dead
Jim
and looking for something to shoot that
do it run away Oh Lucy you walked right
into me shooting someone seen any of
your shootings aha
you can attack you literally backpedal
right into the end of my barrel I'm
guessing some more just down Lucy some
more dudes it was kind of brutal savage
rekt see no I want to help you right now
but you're shooting right in front of me
blue friendly fire why are these zombies
just and sticks in the middle of nowhere
making me run nobody makes me run nobody
makes me bleed my own blood of them ok
well the party the games just stop
caring with these ones I'm just getting
challenge after challenge running back I
generally think my games crash cuz it
just keeps on giving me money I don't
know what's happening oh my God look at
your money that's all right
like what's gumbo I have no idea what's
just happens your game wait where's the
coffee
oh good you've got 998 combo I am oh
wait is that because he was shooting me
I was just it's about to go down you may
achieve it and everything right that is
[ __ ]
you don't know my skills my red did
change me when I you show you when I use
my dad I I got like a ridiculous combo
Christ
oh god it's happening to me now yeah wow
wave 7 seemed to be a lot sure this does
let's go I saw my combo skills are like
now and I'm miss giving up
all right I'm going to the coffin I got
984 combo wait the coffee has
disappeared oh my dear oh dear who
there's some kind of bug this is where
the coffins meant to be and this is
where it spawned and that's where it
also vanished from Oh Daisy look at that
area like yourself you're
backwards-compatible ears and as
compatible as you think is what's
happening here 9 is thing I don't
remember where there's lightning and
thunder going up the background
eliminating the remaining undead is
freaking out like crazy wait guys means
we don't know it means we're not gonna
get any ammo [ __ ] she's not wrong make
every day count every shot must count Oh
waves are just disappearing as well
what's happening look I'm here oh my god
the curvature literally with a second to
go whoo that bizarre I have like a hot
nearly $100,000
what's happening to this game I kind of
like it
your hand brown they're coming up it's
definitely new this didn't happen in the
360 are we doing those acts of God those
those are the holy wars or the coughing
blowing up
I mean we've bee in our previous record
well yeah I mean they're why I think
we've given in though
coughing down vanish okay coven is here
I've just got text on my screen as late
it just has chain and big green lads
chain okay what does the coffin exploded
did we get anything there are so many
zombies
it's too tricky I have a permanent 998
combo the waves are like much faster as
well yeah I mean I don't pop in
what is your cover please secret Eva's
glad some ice cream look how much money
why do you have a permanent night engine
no you come I don't know the coffin
content what the same bugger for my god
somehow
maybe I should just let the combo run
out Oh kicking off again
maybe you're just too skilled whoa
also anything darken in you know black
water now and I cause you dancing
these are taking a lot of bullets to
kill we definitely need coffins the full
balls where's the coffee the noise of it
if you stay with me for sex de Jong oh
god it blew up as I put my hands into it
all right Mike I'm trying to let my
combo run out but it's not okay I'm
letting it run out because it's kids too
much now I run out run out right now
this is like the biggest homo nope Ivan
I have a core of a million dollars I'm
the richest cowboy that ever existed
Jesus what the hell what do I even spend
this much money on dolphin come on
raiveer maybe we know the bugs gone all
the bugs will go oh thank god nice okay
music I'm using undead bait cuz there's
a bloody loader oh my god oh thank you
I'm your guardian angel tomorrow oh wow
nice
my big shotgun big plays oh no yeah now
that bugs gone the waves have gone back
to the normal length as well oh crap get
away from me you should torture to get
into a sticky situation I think Birnam
the taking so much yeah I think happened
was that I maybe was in like
semi-permanent deadlines cuz I was doing
like loads of damage as well oh I'm
sorry my entire back portion wait oh my
god
how are you still alive fatty coming for
you Lucy Oh Pat took five shotgun shells
to kill from both of us Jesus why is he
not dying ow
Christ
I think this is how hard the way was
supposed to be Oh fight behind you
sorry sorry apologizing to me there for
some reason stress attention what would
be in our previous best like we earned
it but phosphorus bullets loaded large
ladies I again there's a large lady full
of show us just back these plus-size
models
I'm not even killed on me about 20
seconds and I've got 400 something combo
error 404 combo no fan I know you're
good at games but this is borderline
ridiculous hacks I'm just standing still
David hax do it I swear this isn't even
my xbox one
this is untampered hardware yeah this is
the Xbox one that we stole from our
office breakout areas may be honest all
these for no they play speak on that one
and we'll FIFA players are hackers guys
why why am I getting $10 over again all
my service my class my neck nope
has anyone seen any zombies guys getting
$10 $10 and a stuffing so on Xbox one
but by clicking poverty is kinda broken
hey smokeless skin wagon that doesn't
smoke that's far away it's like that
song oh my god time I've left you I'm
sorry Nikki attempt coming for you we
ride together we die together
I press the pro barn on the dynamite and
his legs for a second I'm gonna explode
it in my hand all right
an enemy just waiting next on my body
that's right I'm scared right coffin
you've got all the money you need combo
has disappeared though just bribe zombie
when you get there
hello Wow
manual chub and tuck wait oh wait
there's another doesn't that's a new
weapon the green one oh we got killed
we've got a minute to kill these zombies
oh we never live again we have to do
another Marathon Man 1 come on tuck is
on the case I just don't look like a
Manuel Pinto oh that's a different story
so you got a chubby belly and you tuck
it into your shorts these two zombies
are fine
good lamb itchy nose $2.00 the book
never happens at the same time it's like
gifted from one plant to another so I
said I had an itchy nose and I was being
attacked by a zombie and a very kindly
itch my nose
I got you fat but then I got so freaked
out oh I don't want the two dollars to
be on my screen anymore no I have too
much money
two dollars to be honest most wild west
America that would be a small fortune at
a get you where tabernacle I don't know
it's out back this thing is like a curio
so shop there's a time limit is if
anybody needs two dollars there I got
you but can you put me fool Lo and Mo
all right I'm going 40 seconds go to
coffee
Oh run to the corner oh god I'm running
in place
okay we can't pull up itself okay cover
me I'll be insulted by spit Oh
you know I don't like the way my way you
saving you so many listen announcer yeah
this announcer is like did you guys have
a plane for a board game woman you've
got a VCR VHS a chess piece yeah the
same thing yeah VCR the VHS magic rocks
okay so what was it was it called
I can't member to go back no the one you
ran something like Meitner but it wasn't
it was the TV show some be just no
Cryptkeeper
yeah that's it the atmosphere that was
it that's the something like nightmare
Oh what's [ __ ] me running from my
dead eye again oh my god Lucy oh God
they're on the church coffins are no
longer move out of the way this bloody
decal oh she's on the block Oh
everything shotgun sales into this enemy
he'll be in the graveyard about to
occupy it
everybody's blue everybody clue save
your ammo let them burn I'm gonna live
just die
something kills rank to this that's
quite a few of them coming this way oh
my god why do why did he hit mommy did
she stop this it's rude all the noises
they make unpleasant okay I have shotgun
bullets
I got blunderbuss though Oh what you
killed me I was I was leaving no way
near you the blunderbuss is so big oh
god the spray pattern the blunderbuss
why I absolutely refuse to before that I
can't believe you killed me saving your
life at the time back inside I used my
Rico Lucy wait you were me I was getting
chased Oh God Lucy's gonna run out of
the world with ya this is a hot phone
nearby wow wow that was amazing Dave on
my screen you floated for a second and
fell over I've been I did fall over for
some reason the bottle falling on the
ground blew me up each bro that quick
nice to stick together
I'm gonna slide his fence sucker-punched
all my days I'm so low I needs me café's
blunderbuss don't fire please don't come
near me with it
I avenged you I don't know this game is
like all kinds of broken on my screen
there's no zombies in front of Dave so
it looks like you're trying to kill Lucy
I knew it go no ready to blackwater
climb the buildings for safety you know
make sense
come on might win the town piss
themselves neither take a roof against
the bank I don't know why aren't you
throwing oh my god
guardian angel I come to me come to me
come didn't ran like my life depended a
you've got Paula dead oh hey where are
you I'm right next to you I'm on the
corner I'm following you
so been nowhere near where we need to be
didn't kill anyone with that
I got seven bullets left what and a
blunderbuss I don't trust it I can't run
with it either and I've got ball action
good not like this not like this fine
what's wrong with you my screens all red
my thumb was getting tired like you're
hunting a for so long I threw some
through some undead bait and throwing a
hole the dynamite I have oh no I run too
far away I could be taking advantage of
this artillery oh the lag the framerate
is not like that that killed none of
them how is it that many zombies this
game is cheesing us it's definitely
teasing there's no way wait a roof here
like we're in under breath fine fine it
wasn't any zombies near you on my screen
can they climb ladders
I don't know they'd kill me wrong the
ladder okay this is my final stand it's
better ma'am I can't get an angle on the
move yeah hello well it's loading
screens there's my strategy
Oh God hahaha straightest legs off the
roof
well but game crashed in the jiggers
closes closes we did mankind on
ourselves proud
I thought we broke Red Dead Redemption
and 13 minutes and we were well paid and
that always way longer than 30 minutes
okay so you're no way 56k yeah how much
should I get wait because because only
havoc on okay you know ah that's the
worst go gold though well then he's feel
cold I got so much look up Matt xpe so
much money I mean the money doesn't do
anything it's just a point system right
so you're still giving me XP never mind
well that was terrifying but hey if any
of you guys watching enjoyed that video
and you want to see more videos like
this one make sure you subscribe to
GameSpot like this one drop us a comment
we'll make sure to read them and buddy
do see how did Tom get 2,000 kills
nice work time I'm proud of you yeah
buddy good boy
you